hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round five of the 2018
batumi chess olympiad again between
world chess championship challenger
Fabiana Caruana and Boris Gelfand
neither of the two need any additional
introduction but I want to just address
the title of the video as in my previous
video I showed a photo of the United
States team and I said that it's not a
very sportsman like of Caruana to not
wear the blue blazer as all of the other
players were wearing it as well well I
don't think Shanklin was wearing it but
he Caron was Lisa were wearing it and a
lot of you haven't noticed as you have
said in the comments that Carwin
actually had his blue blazer tucked away
behind behind his chair and this is
something you will see the port above
the board it reminds me of the people
who might work in the 1950s hamburger
joint the first thing you will see in
the description below is an interview
for chess comm news but my client
interviews the Fabiano Caruana
our corona addresses his game against
which marathon are and and also this
game against Boris Gelfand
and the end there he mentions that why
he isn't wearing this a blue blazer and
I don't know I think I think he car went
waste look you know very very nice in
the blue blazer but okay to each his own
so that being said we do have a nice
photo there you have it the photo is by
Mari Amelia Nova I will put a couple of
links to her social media in the
description below
there you have it before the game even
started a nice full of Caruana and
gelfand so let's see what happens here
and it's a very nice game I'm sure
you'll enjoy it
a very feisty game Khurana again has the
white pieces and he opens with E 4 we
have C 5 the Sicilian defense Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 Bishop to b5 now Dinesh
Medina of Arras Alamo attack gatling
goes for g6 we have Bishop characters D
captures on c6 and now d3 black black
has doubled pawns but it's a standard
idea against this attack but in return
our black will have this very nice
a diagonal for his dark square bishop
and also black does have the bishops
pair now Bishop to g7 h3 limiting the
options of development for this dark
square Bishop blacks light square Bishop
Knight to f6 nice to see three are both
players Castle and here we have nice to
e8 a popular idea which the black piece
is keeping his options flexible and
white hat a white has to decide what to
do here karmana goes Bishop to e3 a nice
developing move comes up with an attack
against the c5 pawn get from the defense
it we have b6 and here car wanna plays
e5 sorry here Corona plays 'if I've and
here it's this is a not a new mover it
happened a lot of times in this position
between a lot of players and here even
though it's a pretty standard idea here
Gibson took 23 minutes to respond with
his next move he plays f6 challenges
kuranes pawn in the center and here I
don't think this was mentioned in the
interview I have listened to the
interview but at this position was on
the board already here rook to e1 was
played in the game and here we have
night to c7 by Caruana this is a
opposition that already happened on the
board it was a game in 2007 between
Lilith McCutcheon and I know Shannon
aware it captures and f6 was played and
I know Shannon I was able to win this
game with the black pieces here Khurana
goes for a different approach he goes
Queen to d2 a standard idea of course
you wanted this Queen and Bishop battery
Bishop is coming to h6 you want to get
rid of black star square bishop but it
does come with a pawn sacrifice so
what's what's the idea behind the pawn
sacrifice well Catherine says okay I
don't think this is this is quite
possible and Gaston prepares a very nice
plan of his own he plays F captures on
e5 and this move is not the win material
but rather to give material
karana continues with his plan we have
Bishop to h6 and here Gelfand realizes
his plan rook captures on f3
and it's it's a very interesting idea
because you'll see what happens here of
course if we play G captures here then
Bishop to f6 is coming and here black
will black will have a very nice
position so instead after rook to f3
first Bishop captures and g7 is played
and now you don't really gain anything
by moving the rook back if you move the
rope back simply Bishop captures here
and now karana
will grab the pawn back and eliminate
Black's dark square Bishop which is a
crucial defending piece here black would
have simply too many dark square
weaknesses around his King I saw dr.
Bishop to g7 King capture Sun g7 g
captures on f3 geffen decided to
sacrifice the exchange and here we have
Bishop captures on h3 so it's hard to
say probably Khurana did not have this
rook sacrifice with black anywhere in
his home analysis as he did spend 18
minutes on his next move does he bring
the Queen straight into the attack or
does he first capture on e5 Khurana
first captures on e5 and here Boris
decides to go east six it's a very nice
move the bishop from h3 is defending the
e6 move and also the e6 pawn and the g6
bones are now creating a very nice
outpost for this light square Bishop on
f5 also the Queen can now come into the
game for example with a via Queen to h4
and as I mentioned in the interview this
night from c7 can really jump around
freely so ok rook to g5 blocking
blocking the Queen and here comes the
Queen to f6 bringing the Queen into the
game this way it comes with an attack
against the f3 pawn karana defends the
f3 pawn will have looked to g3 and the
now comes Bishop to f5 and now we see
that the elephant's light-square bishop
it really is a monster here Khurana does
have two rooks but it's very hard to
make use of them as a karana has no ippo
nor orgy pawn there's really no way to
to get rid of this bishop you'd have to
find some way to attack it with the
knight but it's not all that easy so
this is really a really a stronghold
here
the rooks rocks will not be able to
penetrate us okay King to g2 Khurana
prepares a mix room for the other rook
to enter the game
we have h5 and then our rook to h1 at
some point as this pawn is pinned the
Khurana will be threatening rook
captures on h5 we have worked to h8 big
elephant and de now comes Knight to e4
okay and get when the does have an
excellent Bishop on f5 but now Khurana
has an excellent knight on e4 you don't
really ever want to capture this as your
Bishop is a very important defensive
piece here so here what do you do with
the Queen you can move it Queen to e7
for example but elephant decides that
perhaps he can even snatch another pawn
he plays Queen captures on b2 and what
happens here well here you can decide
for to go for a lot of things Queen to
g5 is an idea but it's easy to decide
against it although it's although it's a
nice move the idea now is of course rook
captures on h5 but perhaps karana
thought that Gelfand could defend it
with Knight to d5 because now if rope
captures then it doesn't work because
after rook captures Queen captures yes
the pawn is pinned but now you have nice
to f4 check winning the Queen but
instead after this Knight to d5 move you
can go c3 and now it's it's a very hard
position for black and it's very hard
for black to actually find a move you
would force h4 here but then you get the
rod captures on h4 captures captures and
here white would still retain a better
position but karana finds a different
idea first he goes Queen to f4 instead
of g5 this comes with an attack against
the knight on c7 we have Knight to d5
this night was coming to d5 at some
point either way and then now Queen to
d6 and now you can see that it's it's
very difficult for guys wanted to bring
his Queen back into the defense here if
you try something like h4 which is most
likely what should what guess one should
have played h4 pretty much secures the
draw after Queen to d7 check King to f8
rook captures now you get rook capture
and the now Queen to d8 will pick up the
rook King moves Queen captures here and
laughter Queen captures on situ it would
be very hard for for whites to make any
progress here but instead perhaps either
get one did not find this find this idea
or he even wanted to want it to go for a
win here so instead he played 'if I've a
very nice move now taking away the f4
square from the White Queen Knight to f4
will now be a very powerful move but
it's also it's also a losing move for
example but Corona did not find this
brilliant idea he found another idea
that's also quite excellent but there is
one really really amazing sequence of
moves so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the idea it's
really a powerful align if you really
feel up to it you know feel free to
check it out but if you don't then you
know I will give it a couple of seconds
as usual for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are you
know above any any any great chess
player because it's really really an
insane line the move is the rook to g1
inviting black to attack your rook and
it does seem that it does seem like your
rook will not have anywhere to go but
after h4 rook captures on g6 this is the
idea
Bishop captures and now King to h2
opening up a discovered attack and now
Queen captures and g6 is the idea after
rook blocks now you get c4 winning back
the piece as now the knight really
doesn't have anywhere to go but you
don't want to move it because the Queen
to f6 check but whatever black plays and
black really doesn't have any useful
moves here the rook is start guarding
the bishop the bishop is pinned here the
Queen has no way of returning if the
knight moves Queen to f6 is coming
whatever whatever black plays white can
simply pick up upon as well then Queen
captures here will be coming and now
black would have to move it for example
Knight here defending the bishop on g6
and
now Quinn can finally come to have sex
with check King to g8 Queen Queen here
attacks the rook rock moves and now
Queen to d8 check King moves Queen to e7
check King moves and now Knight to f6
this comes with check King h8 and Queen
to a fate will be checkmate this is only
one of the lines that is winning for
white there are plenty more but Rock to
g1 a very hard silent and deadly move to
find that leads to a win for white
Khurana finds a different plan instead
he goes for rook to h4 instead of this
rook to g1 idea now were white
practically invites black to push h4
Colonel Khurana simply prevents h4 we
have Queen to d4 big elephant and you
could go for Knight to a4 would check
and after the King moves
bring your rook into the game and this
would have in fact been the best idea
for Gelfand as now the h5 point is
defended by the knight and the white
would still have to decide how to make
make progress here probably Knight to g5
and then continue pushing but instead
Queen to d4 was played by elephant and
now Caruana please King to g1 doesn't
allow night to afford to come with check
and rook to f8 now here Gelfand decides
to give up the h5 pawn and he thinks he
thinks he he is out of the woods we
could say corona things differently he
plays rook captures on h5 and now we
have Bishop captures on e4 and then our
gala fans idea is pretty clear here why
he gave up the h5 pawn if you play F
captures any 4 then of course Zephyr
Queen captures on f2 white is lost on
the other hand after Bishop 3 4 if you
played D captures only 4 again
Knight to f4 is coming and now you're
already threatening to exchange Queens
you're threatening to grab the rock and
h5f threatening 90 to check to win to
win back the exchange here so a very
nice idea for black but he misses one
line and it's it's not that hard to
actually miss this so again feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
refutation of elephants idea I'll give
you a couple of seconds
you know just for you to decide whether
you want to do it or not for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just refuted a
very nice attack from Boris Gelfand the
idea is Queen to d7 check and now you
see the problem here if you block with
the rook rook to f7 you get a rope to h7
a very familiar idea I'm sure for all of
you King captures Queen captures on f7
King has to move and now comes Queen to
f8 doesn't matter where the King goes
for example if he goes here you get rook
to h3 if he goes here you get Quinn to
h8 and this will be checkmate on the
other hand after this Queen to d7 check
if you don't block if you move the King
let's say go King here you get queen -
h7 and again this is checkmate
so Geffen played the only other possible
move and that is King to f6 and now the
problem is you can capture with the F
pawn which was previously impossible
because the rook and Queen were eyeing
the f2 pawn so here you can simply
recapture Khurana doesn't recapture
immediately he decides to grab a pawn
first Queen captures on c6 because why
not
King back to g7 and karana simply
repeats Queen to d7 check King to f6 and
only now F captures on e4 comes with an
attack on the night if you move the
knight and notice that King the g1 was a
very important move for Caruana because
if the King was in g2 you would now have
Knight to f4 check picking up the White
Queen so a very nice attacking idea King
to g1 by Caruana nice - a forest played
and here again a very nice a very nice
situation where for example a move like
rook to g6 check would would be winning
for example King captures now you get
into h7 and the King is in the mating
that simply King f6 check King moves
Queen checks on g7 Knight has the block
Queen captures king f4 and now Queen to
g3 will be checkmate but Corona finds an
even nicer idea here after Knight to f4
Corona plays rook to f5 check now the
black King has no squares left you have
to capture the rook we have pawn
captures and now comes Queen captures on
f5 King to e7 and after row to g7
here on move 33 Boris Gelfand resigned
the game so again a very nice very nice
idea in the previous game Caruana
defeated former world champion which
monitamon and this time he beats Boris
Gelfand so a very impressive streak for
Fabiana Caruana he did start the Olympia
with two draws but then three wins in a
row against very impressive players and
with this victory
he's now I believe less than 10 rating
points from Magnus Carlsen as Khurana is
the second highest rated player in the
world so there are a couple of more
rounds left in the Olympiad so if he
does really well perhaps he can even
become the highest rated player in the
world before his World Chess
Championship match with Magnus Carlsen
of course what if you resign well if you
move the king then you lose the rook if
you play something like this then Queen
ch-check Queen has to block only move
Queen c6 and now the king has no more
squares you have to block Queen captures
will be checkmate so against on the
resigns after rook to g7 and really
really an impressive game also I wanted
to ask you what do you think I mean what
do you think are really Coronas chances
of taking away the World Chess
Championship title from Magnus Carlsen
as you know in 2013 when Carlsen
challenge which won at an island for the
title he took the title away from Anand
without losing a single game then in the
2014 World Chess Championship match it's
in the return match cause I only lost
one game to be found on Anand and in the
2016 World Chess Championship match
across and vs. Sergey Karjakin cousin
also only lost one game so in three
world chess championship matches so far
cousin lost two games so it's it seems
like Carlsen loses less than one game
per World Chess Championship match so
what what are really kiwanis chances
your water here's his strengths and can
can he improve on this can he can he
make a difference something I wanted to
ask you and yeah that's basically the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and that
you're enjoying the
the limpid so far here are the results
after round five as you can see in first
place with perfect scores our Azerbaijan
the Czech Republic and Poland yes and
also also Ukraine then as the United
States couldn't win the game the match
against Israel
even though Kirwan achieved this very
impressive victory over Boris Gelfand
same Shanklin lost onboard force and
Hikaru and Nakamura drew their games so
the match was a draw so here you have it
with with four points United States four
points and the draw so four and a half
points the United States Israel and the
Germany then you have with four points
Iran India China France Netherlands then
you have with also four points Norway
Russia Bosnia Herzegovina Turkey Armenia
Slovakia Croatia and Macedonia so there
we have it some some of the results it's
gonna be a very very you know a nice
Olympiad so once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Roger
Rothman Alexander Korda have undressed
Fischer Michael Carr and Steven Behrens
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with another
interesting video and the thing in the
top left corner free mark Wiebe it's
it's a it's a form of support for a
subscriber of mine he's having a very
hard time so I hope everything works out
too well and that all is all everything
works itself out and a huge you know
really thank you to all your friends for
having such huge support for you so
really be well soon so thank you all and
I'll see you soon